today's global snack takes us up into
the mountains Cusco is located in the
heart of Peru's Andes at an elevation of
3400 meters once the capital of the Inca
Empire Cusco is now a popular tourist
magnet and anyone wanting to sample some
local cuisine heads for the cities san
pedro market there are many different
stands offering a wide variety of food
net a kiss baku sea bass specializes in
Peru's number-one vegetable the potato
she learned how to prepare the different
varieties from her mother
when the meme I'm not coming I've been
helping out here since I was a child and
my mother passed on all her know-how to
me today mother and daughter are
preparing a very special potato soup
called SOPA de Moorea Moorea is a
variety of potato that is freeze-dried
it's laid out in the Sun until it turns
pale and then crushed it's the main
ingredient for the soup shredded Papa
Lisa another variety of potato Mar added
as well as broad beans some finely
chopped root vegetables and pork now we
add some Pike Oh her think of a more
flavor this is what pine cone looks like
Piko is a kind of mint it's also good
for the digestive system a good additive
when cooking with beans
the beans are added later on with some
spinach leaves on top to garnish the
soup
why is it so tasty year because they use
ingredients that you can only find in
Peru
like a special kind of potato different
kinds in fact and that's what makes this
a typical Peruvian dish tipico para one
la comida then when provecho